[Music]
and
good afternoon everyone how are you doing
very well today well first of all I want to tell you
that I'm super happy to be here
talking about hanging because I
like hanging a lot
what we're going to see today is basically
like  pending has evolved in the
same way that
all the technologies used
to build applications have evolved, all
cloud technology
pending has also had to make
many changes to adapt to the state
of things as they are now and that
is  what we intend to give with this
session is an idea of what the curre
t state of things is with aventin so that you c
n get an idea of how to apply it to your app
ication projects before anyt
ing else you have to present me your and jorge nogales I a
a chaste I would understand  in
the google cloud team in madrid and
as surely because ashton the
engineer does not come to us at all to tell you that
basically my work and it is one thing that
I adore for another  What I do is to meet with
many of you who tell me about the
challenges you have in your work and
in your projects and understand more or
less how we can solve it with
our pieces, one of them with an app
engine, but well, for not putting it
later, you can approach me, come on, I think  who
is already talking to some of you
we felt free to contribute and
tell me about the challenge you have
we are going to start with the small one in a
bit of definition for people who
are not used to using the app
engine it is basically a
co-managed platform for  that you can
run your applications without having
to worry about the infrastructure
that is running all the
background applications we like to think
of beijing as a system where
you do the code we
take the code we build the
application and start running it
on top of our infrastructure  in such a
way that at no time do you have to
worry about a  server,
memory goes down, goes up, I have a computing peak, it
launched more instances,
all of this is done by google for you if
you want to be able to think that your
application is running one
of google's datacenters, which is the case, on the
other hand, these teachers who have already been
in  use for a lot of time are
the ones that are providing services such as
google search, youtube, gmail maps, what we
propose with this talk and with the app
engine is that you benefit from all that,
from all the knowledge that we have
stored up from all these years so that
everything  what we have
self-managed infrastructures
can benefit you from it by using the app
engine which is what this talk
is about I forgot to mention it before but we have
intended with this talk that it be
eminently practical so
at times we will ask you to take out
your laptops our mobiles and
browse  to some demos that will surely
fail there is no truth mario but well
surely you will like them
sir  from where they are applied 21 because in many
places but basically where they sell it
shows all its potential in the
execution of
pending web applications supported, for example, languages such as ru
y or php that make it very simple to generate a
ebsite the scale execu
ion of this site  web no
we have also seen an explosion of platforms
that are using the app engine as the
back-end of mobile applications
since snap chat comes to mind
imagine the scale that this requires and
other gaming companies are
using appendino as a
tool of a  website or a
tool that runs a website
but for a go that of course for
all the infrastructure behind it
to offer a pending http path
that is a great use case to
use it especially in conjunction with
another product that is  calls
[Music]
that is inside the cloud that basically
what it does is give access to
the programmatic apis in such a way that it does not  You
can forget about putting in on foot
this authentication of login users,
all of that is solved by cloud in bridge, which
is the part that we say acs, that
wrapper to the pgje http that you offer,
there is another example of
use cases where they learn  it is very good that it is
in corporate applications so to
give you a piece of information the majority of
corporate applications in google are based on
app engine and this is something that we
find very recurrently as
companies build their
internal portals management applications and all
that based on the  elements of the app
engine
[Music]
if we had to see where it is
located within the entire range
of computing products seen and as a
pyramid starting from the bottom
we find all the part of mars and
donkey marc of infrastructure the
virtual machines networking
surely yes  you have a
legacy application or because a database that
needs to be executed in a
virtual machine, then  Starting with
virtual machines in this sense makes a
lot of sense to us more than app
engine on the other hand if you are
familiar with the idea
of dockers container because in our platform we ha
e google container engine which you c
n access even because vernet is to
deploy  your work clouds
then if it is in your case I governed
test and container engine is a great
option for you within the
most part of villas no the next step is already
app engine apennines the platform is a
platform for itself that will let you
execute your  applications without
serving them completely without having to
worry about infrastructure from when
you have to scale from when you have to
decrease the number of distances all
that is solved by the app engine for you
finally at one more point at one
more level of abstraction are the
function-based architectures here
I'm thinking about things like you leave
a file in a storage that  e
fires an event that calls a function
that calls another to another web or that does
a certain business logic this is
where the whole part of cloud
functions that we have been seeing in
these sessions comes in and that we will continue to
see
as I said we intend that this  be
quite practical so we have
oriented the presentation to give you tricks
that you can do with the app engine and the
first trick that we are going to tell you is
how to go from code to production in a
single command that seems like a
somewhat magical thing but that is what I know  get
with the penchyna
and that command I am referring to
is called cloud up to play
what this command does is imagine that you are
developing our code local environment it
takes all your code it
packages it the cloud uploads it and starts
executing it as an application  that which
seems very simple, all the people who
work with the app engine already have it
as very accepted because it does a number
of things inside behind that  they are
quite interesting which are the ones we are
going to see today imagine a project
with one of js
we have on our local computer a
javascript file plus the package point
j are that basically defines the
structure and how I want the
dependencies of my application to be shown to me when
we launch  that command takes all of that,
packs it up and leaves it in cloud storage a
kind of directory with my
source code that we do later with that because
we pack it again and build
a
docker container that in turn we push to the
app engine container registry
so that  so that any user who
enters using the oad balance that is
also instantiated with this command can
access the three instances that are going
to be running from the app engine to a rock,
a very stable system like
all of ours, but there can always be
scheduled maintenance events  or
unscheduled that basically
disable a compute zone
that's why every time you launch
this pdi play command what is
executed is in the same region three
different instances in three
different zones so that if in a serious one you are
seeing an event something happens because
our application continues to execute
all this happens behind
and not only this but  that every time and to
respond to a computing peak that
you have imagine a
travel reservation company in June or hotel reservations
etc. ticket sales
to respond to those computation peaks
there is an element called
auto skater that basically what  it does
is pick up and raise the instances to
manage all the peak traffic that
we have at a given time
all that behind it does up display of
this part we always forget but it is
part of the application deployment the
part of the
automatic scaling login balancing of  loading
monitoring checking how
our application is doing all of this
automatically offers 20 which is a part
that we forgot  a but what is
important when executing and monitoring an
application
for some time we have been
working on another let's say version of
adventin which we call the standard flexible'
app engine when it was born it
supported four languages and now we have
xtended it to  support languages such as on
of blond js or dot net or even
hy not if your language is not the o
e you use in your compa
y or for a specific piece suppo
ted we will be able to allow it throu
h the flexible app engine' the one that gener
tes is a dockery image that execu
es it  It is also using all the
app engine with the advantages that this has
in auto scaling,
monitoring, etc., etc.,
etc.,
all these services that I mentioned
have that law of 99 95%, all are valid,
flexible standard, any language,
any service that is running
in the app engine has  this level of
service
with this we basically go to trick
number 2 what is trick number  ro 2
well, trick number 2 before mentioned
that one of the languages that we have relea
ed for flexible appengine is dot net a
d for a few weeks it has been possible to run d
t net koren code in app engin
in such a way that our code is gi
en a  runtime that knows how to
interpret dot net core and execute
our application perfectly
and this is possible because a few weeks ago,
as I said, we launched the app
engine to support
execution loads of applications in dot
network, what does this really mean,
well, this involves certain
things one has  a runtime that knows how to
understand, interpret and execute that
dot net code a lot of
information and not only information in the
form of tutorial documentation but
code examples that you can download
on the web that we will see later a
container a container that you can
take and execute it well  in
container engine in cabernet it is
whatever you want you can take it because  e is
because the entire series of libraries is public
so that you can access
all the services offered in
google cloud and of course
management tools and
development tools
this is the web page where we offer
all the resources related to dot net
es  cloud google.com
where it is and you can find all the
resources that I have mentioned
before tutorials
code examples code lapse libraries
etc everything is here
we have a commitment as you may have
noticed from all the talks that it is
open in the cloud and part of  that is to
provide the community with the tools
and the code it needs to
evolve in this case on github
google cloud platform you can find
specifically in dot net all the
code examples runtime tools you are
surprised here here you can download and
start messing with all this  for
for dot net
regarding the tools that I
mentioned before as not for the
deployment of a  dot net applications in
enap understand we have developed a
plugin that integrates with that to the studio
that in one click allows you to explain all
your code in visual studio in the app
engine not only deploy it but also
see the versions you have allows you a
certain ease of administration
this leads us to the next trick
the next trick is to change
a bit the philosophy that we had the
idea that we had platforms more
normally platforms forever
sitting with a wall that is the fact of
having to use a library that
was not in my runtime  the fact of having
to make a call to the
operating system that is not supported well
we don't think this has to
be the case so one thing we have
done is allow you to
customize jce the round
time images that you are going to be running  our
application in what way then installing
libraries adding commands creating a
directory structure is the p  You can
customize to your liking,
let's give an example of all this,
this is me with a caliber in my head,
surely you ask what I do in the
office with a caliber, but that is
outside the session, you can ask me, I am not
mentally insane as you think  some
of my colleagues the project that
I am talking about that we are going to give as an
example of this is customization of
this customization of images is a
project that we are going to demonstrate here
consists of I want to create a card that
basically consists of an image
that is going to  take my computer
and compose it in such a way that it does a
certain processing of the image that makes it
round that makes it this
size and drinks it inside the
largest letter so that it can be offered on the
web and can be tweeted in this case
how do you do that then if it comes to
mind to use image magic which is the
swiss army knife image editing well it
's my local mac then I take it I install it and
might magic yf  I see that graphics
magic is also cool because it gives you
a slightly higher layer of abstraction
africa fix magic relies on the
footage that gives me certain
functionalities and apart from that there is a
non-js module that I can use to
do all these transformations because
it is helping me  lo and magic everything works
perfectly on my computer but what
happens as what is supposed to hang well no
problem because we have docker and it is the
first demonstration that we wanted to
do
through dockers I get that this code
can be executed in the app engine this is
the code of  the function that we have
deployed and that basically sends the
photo that is captured with my
computer's webcam to the server is a
hyper simple function what it does is that it
takes the image that comes to me in
the http request it stores it in  a
temporary directory on my disk
and then what it is going to do is call the
gm module the g module is
the way the wrap see what it offers you
no js to access gra  phics matica is
an n pm module
that is supported by graphics matic
so if I don't have graphics magic
installed I have a little problem
in the app engine how do I get that well
this is the code of my application
that is in this in this directory well
we  we have a command
what is this conflict that is going to make me
is
and create a docker file that
basically is going to be the one that executes
this tandem or js run in the app engine
for what will
you return
this box to see what a real time demo
is  error included what it is
doing is right now it has generated
a docker file for me with, as I say, the
definition of the doc container which is going
to be executing this in the app engine and
on the other hand it is going to modify me
jamel so that to indicate  to
beijing which is a castón image let's
see what this looks like
the file I called the ex extremely
simple I tell him that I want to use the
flex flexible environment' and my runtime is going to
be castón that runtime well  this here
this is the definition of my docker file
of the runtime that is going to execute my
application in the app engine what we have to
do because it is very simple very simple
if I remember the commands and I don't do
anything stupid but here Maria gave me
a hand
Basically what I want
before I start to install all the
dependencies of I don't leave this is what I
want to install two packages image magic
and graphics magic because this is how it is in
ubuntu
apt-get
- and update to update the
in the repositories and  then apt-get
minus and minus q to make it interactive
and tell it to install image
and graphics magic that what we wanted
with this when it's creating
kerr image and right now we're going to see what it's
going to do is run that before
download all the dependencies of con
young
then everything is fine so you
can see you can even
build your own docker with this
bild touch we are going to put a photo on it and let
the local take it for me
le
web
this keyboard
ok if you look this has nothing to do
with app engine stoker and it has taken the
file that I have it is taking the
ranking that it has downloaded from the app
engine it is starting to compile its
container I am not going to leave it because it
takes a while  little but it is for you to see that it
is extremely standard so
when I am ready with all this with
put google app deploy what it is going to
do is start the whole process of
taking the code compile my image my
container upload it to pendin and execute
everything that  we have seen everything we
have seen before
so after unfolding it I
invite you to try it if you go to
photo next dot spot dotcom well you are going
to be able to see what this does what
it does
let's see
photo next
dot to dot com
there we are, my goodness, good for the camera and
we are going to do it together come
a dose
because what he has done has been to take the
photograph of the person sent to that jungle who has not even
made the series of transformations
that c  I was thinking of this so that this doesn't come out
almost better than he didn't tweet it, not because
of maintaining dignity a bit,
but here basically it is by pressing the button
this tweet, this this this post is self-generated,
which you can of course in more,
I invite you to post it
and this in a very easy way because
we have managed to manipulate the runtime
that my application is going to execute to do
what I want and you do not have to
stop at the fact that there is no specific library for
that runtime that barrier no
longer exists with the app engine
to continue a bit  with the tricks we go
to the next one this if you look is a
fairly monolithic application in the
same js module I have a process
that uploads an image to me in the capture it
saves it on disk it
calls the module it makes the
transformations to the image processing module it
does the  transformations and
leave it again in the cloud storage okay
and then it takes all that and sends
the response to everything in the same module
well this may not be
I don't know to  the best way is to deploy an
application in production then
surely all of you have
encountered the problem of creating an application
of this type upload it so that we go from 10 to
10 million users and then
friends come the
scalability problems as a couple all this in
pieces  so that everything scales better
and this of course leads us to use
architectures based on microservices
in such a way that I take the scalpel,
take my application and break it
down into pieces that functionally make
sense
which pieces make sense because in
our case we have thought that for  to make
a simple case, two pieces make sense,
one that occupies the entire
front part, in this case, what it is going to do
is open the web interface, it is going to load
all the part of that of taking the
photograph and it is going to send the photograph to
another  module as it is sent
through a worker pattern that in this
case is implemented with pause for
sap it is our product of me  Messaging
here the front-end would be sending a
message with the image that reaches the
receiver in this case in the part of the
pack in which it takes that image and performs
all the operations that we have seen
here if you notice we are decoupling
the two things so that  Imagine that,
as we will see later, the part of the
back that needs more resources, a
different type of machine, this is
what will allow the application to be distributed
in such a way that scaling
different parts is much more
efficient than scaling one, everything goes, how
is this achieved with  an app engine
also very easy by
adding a label to our file
to djamel imagine that we have 17
services that make up our
application because then we
would have to have 17 abdomen and in
each one add a label that
put services and the name of the
service and display  This will allow us to
deploy each one of them
separately and not only that, but also the
management that it does pending  below it
will be individualized with each of
these packages in such a way that if there is
a module that is not a service that is not
touched very frequently then it will be
there turned off in general the costs are worth
and of course the magic command
after  that we have all this abdi play and
we would already have it ready
that allows us to have what
the fact of having an architecture
based on microservices allows us not only to
distribute the load and that in the app engine
everything scales more efficiently it
allows us to integrate very
different technologies in  the different parts that
we have in our application what happens
if I don't want to use one of js I'm going to
put today flamenco
and I'm going to use dogs so I don't see
anything with the lights but I want to use it
on a daily basis
because this is going to be  very useful
for those who do not notice that they learn it
is also capable of running but let's take a
look at let's take a look at the
code
do not expect me
precisely  Let's do a lot of
frills. This is a
very simple application script that
basically uses a framework that
you may know called muy or lisis
that basically implements a
web server and in this case what we are doing is
capturing the call to the directory  root
of our web server and we are
returning a template that we are going to
render later, what does that
template look like, well, a very simple image,
a green background that says
welcome bareback or something like that,
welcome, but it's worth it, let's
see what it looks like
then, sorry,
how do you support stand up in ying? Well,
here again, the touch file is our
friend in docker file. Note that
I'm not even starting from a grand
time that gives me a hangover. I'm
bringing one from the community that supports it,
but  which is the part above that from
I am bringing a dock air file that
apparently knows how to execute but later
to this part it has added the  framework
that I need with cl basically I download
it and leave it installed I expose certain
port variables sorry through an
environment variable I copy my application
and it executed as simple as that
I already have my super application but
we already have it deployed here
and then this is  the way it looks
and this code here is obviously very
simple but what it has behind it is
that
back end in quotes because it is
using mayol and if it is to serve
this web page, notice that ppl would not
bet anything that it is not mentioned for
nothing the documentation of the app engine
but you see that it is possible to run language
is somewhat exotic between quotes
sorry for the fans of pers
not only with pelé imagine swift if
you are ios developers because
you will be more than familiar with this
we also allow the execution of
suites as well in this case the
application is very simple it is also
an application that is basically going to
use a framework that is  he calls
culture and he's going to do the hello world
writing he's going to put it to run in the app
as a team without much ado it has the dow
care file because the touch file
looks like this one it
starts with that rent of a point that
includes swift and basically  what is
running is the web server this is the
texture framework no more no less
we have this version also
displayed here and this is what is presented
when we upload the dow that when we do
cloud up display and upload this abdomen
what we what we are going  let's see in apple
you have this part here this is an
example of how to support languages that perha
s we could not even think that they
re supported in a slope using docke
in the same way a dock the one that you h
ve as a result of your conti
uous integration syste
you can upload to any
public registry and tell the pendin hey run
this dock the one we have here
if you have what can be done in the app
engine
let's go with the next trick
is  This is basically what I have told you
before
but not only but swift which scales
any language that you can
think of and is supported by an image to be
observed that can be executed
with the app engine, benefiting from all
the auto scaling features in the
absence of infrastructure that  we have
mentioned before if you have a touch it
can be run in the app engine
if we are going to bring this architecture
we have mentioned it as a possible solution to
a performance problem but
we certainly have not seen the
performance we have not been able to
see it so what I wanted to show you
here  it's like in a very easy way with
adventure to see how my application is performing
so if we go to the
console
in the control panel app engine you
join board that basically what it
shows you how much the application has been used
in different ways it has
different views this the amount  of
requests let's see the photos and
this is the number of requests per
second that we have been
receiving this is the latency of the
requests in different percentiles
we can see the use of the cpu that
this infrastructure is running once the
peak that there on June 7
around 4 in the afternoon or so and a  something that
is very important it also allows you to see
the instances that have been deployed look at
what
allows you different time scales
but there is an interesting thing and it is how the
app engine works for whatever it is
surely because my children were testing at
home when they saw that it
could be done  photos were pi pi pi pi
pi and on the 6th at 6 o'clock we studied
playing around a lot with aventín that
the stair car did what the stair car says
is to climb two more instances
to support the load that was being
generated it goes without saying  that there
has been no
human manipulation in that it has been this component
that has detected the load and that has
decided to increase the number of instances
to accommodate the load q  ue came to you it
is very easy to see
how my application is performing in
beijing
no I was not happy just with the part
of the image I
wanted to make a video okay then
we are going to make a fool of ourselves a little
more
the idea of this is to make an application that
instead of a static image that I
saw on this card to tweet what
I did, it is a video that generates an
animated gif fooling around and also
because twitter here forces me to do
this well in terms of bookstores because it
forced me to change  image magic to efe
efe mp and somehow that image mati
which is the swiss army knife of the
images
efe efe mp is from this video ok
so he used efe mp but this implies
that the virtual machine because the
virtual machine is hanging I need a
little the machine that is
running the learner application below
needs more resources obviously
video editing video manipulation
more expensive in terms of cpu
than processing  images
but with the app engine this is also
solved because because you are able to
define the hardware that the hardware
can somehow size the
machine that runs and adapt it to the
needs of each resource like
basically modifying three parameters
this makes use of a feature of
google computing which consists of
gastón machín that allows you to specify
how many cpu how much memory and how much
disk you want for your machine
in my case this is the standard machine
that works well for most
cases in the app engine but in my case it is
a bit special because  I'm doing
video processing,
surely I don't need as much memory,
so I could define less or as much
disk, but I need a lot of cpu to do
that expensive video editing process,
no, how is this done, because the same
file obviously with three more lines,
we are going to define what  we want to double the
cpu that we are using and we
want to use less memory than  the one
that gives us the app engine to adapt the
machine to the work it has to do,
which in this case is to process the video
having seen the phones again
come here mario let's
beat next dot spot dotcom
then let's see if everything goes  well
aps pot.com
we allow the use of the video here we leave
marillo again here and now it's a
bit of doing what's wonderful
in principle now what he has done has
been to take the video and he has sent it to
pendin it was he is doing with efe mp  he
is converting it to an animated gif,
surely he will lower the resolution
so that when he has a good time,
generate this thesis for us, generate the
letter with this animated team, which has
been the process that has made me
the video processing back-end module,
it
is  very powerful
we are going to finish this is the
architecture that we had proposed
for today that basically has
executed the many themes that we have
seen but at the moment this is usually
quite different from  e any
application in production where we have
our front-end that communicates there was
a messaging service with the pack
in which in turn makes use of a
virtual machine that is running a
database that in turn calls an api that
is for  there it returns an
image to you is guided and all this is
stored in managers and this is not
more like a real
production application
because the good thing is that they hung it is
extremely simple with the
libraries that we have left to make use of
all the services  from google cloud
spanair cloud e-mail vision intelligence
shavit query any platform
any service that is app engine
it can be called sorry in google cloud
it can be called from app engine very
easily with the libraries
if you are working in js or it is
as easy as  do nm mh nm install
this this google cloud module if you
work on python pib and you work on
the rubin game and this is basically what
it costs to send a  I say the photo of a dog
by its name
when viewing it and that they write us with sunshine to
the different tags that they have counted on
the image in those four lines
the problem would already be solved well with
all this I have finished my part I
leave you with Mario  'I'm still going to
tell you more things about the app engine,
good afternoon, I'm María Arienza, as
it says, she works at Capsid, Capsid, we
are dedicated to the design
and automation and continuous operation of
critical digital platforms, and this
year we are especially happy
because it is a very  special for the
cloud you know why it is a special year
for the cloud because in 2017 after
30 years the people of the
world meteorological organization that is an
organization that belongs to the
united nations has decided to release volume 3
of the world cloud atlas  world
cloud atlas then we to
celebrate that in capsid we have
invented a kind of game like what
need to have this organization
when they want to promote these new
clouds, think that in this volume of the
atlas they are naming
clouds that previously had no name, and that
comes in handy because now we can
refer to them by their name,
that's fine, so we've created a
kind of game  an application that
we would make available to this
organization so that they could see which are
the clouds that people like the most,
so I am going to show you how we have
assembled this application and how we
have used the app engine
to work,
a bit of a spoiler there, but ok  look
here we have the application deployed
as it is now as you can
imagine this started as a game and
well those of us who were doing that
knew how to develop in python and
we had some pre-created application and
we had used that skeleton to
put it here deploy you know
version 1  that you can see there right now
that version is not absorbing 100%
of the traffic that means that e  The
balancer that the app engine puts in
front of you is going to receive 100% of the
requests and it is going to send them to this
version 1 ok
simply because I am making that
balance what you see there
we are now going to see a use case within the
app engine  that what it will allow
is a transition from this version 1 to a
second version or rather in this
case what we are going to try is to do
a test once to see which of the two
versions works better which ones we like
more and we will see how  We can do paging them in
a very, very,
very simple way, so let me
first do the configuration of what
we want, I'm simply going to take my
version 1 and my version 2
and I'm going to say that I want to send 50%
of the traffic  to version 1 and the other 50
to version 2 you can think of this
scenario for several cases for example
the testing bird for example to put
our version 2 into production without
any down time is fine and whatever
comes to mind then  simply
doing that having my two versions
deployed and deciding what percentage
of traffic I am going to send to each one and
clicking here on sorry clicking I am going to
change it from the cookie I always make
mistakes I am
going to remove it by
clicking here on save I already have my
application
what I have  is that the balancer
will send 50% of the traffic to version
1 and 50% of the traffic to version 2
so that you all get to work
we have created that short url that what it is going
to do is point to the url that it is
managing  the load balancer and it
will be that balancer that begins to
send traffic to each of the
versions as it arrives, it is time
for you to enter the application and well,
if you like the cloud that you see and the name
it has, then you can give it  I like it
and we will use that this is because
business people are beginning to put
pressure on us and are telling us that they want
real metrics, not how the application turns out in
the end, they are the ones who are going to give
you  have to pay them and how
good it is for me in this case
this is the image that is in version
2 and this is a powerful cloud that has been
given a name or mojen and you because
these are the clouds that we men generate
in  the other version then you will see it you will
see another type of cloud another thing that
we have done within the application and it
is not quite right this is the moment
because it is here absolutely coupled
that is to say this is part of the versions
that we have uploaded is to create this service
It is a kind of dashboard where
our business people go to see how
the application is doing and what we
have there are simply the two
versions, version 1 is the one with the
clouds that form the waterfalls,
version 2 is the clouds that we humans form.
and what we have there is also
a couple of bars where the blue tells us
the number of times that image has been shown
and the red the number of times
it has visited in likes here on this
side there is on this side you
you have the only version that you have version 2 and in
livenation simply dividing the
number of likes by the number of
times the image will be printed is a
kind of conversion metric that they are going
to use to know which version is liked
more
good in this  At the moment what we have is
to pass this application on to our
development team and in our
development team
I have told you before that this application
this champions is reusing some
old code in this
development team they are not very payton there is one
thing they like  it is not of js so
well what they have done when they
have taken external control of this
application is not of js and they have put this
version 3 in a kind of
beta we have it and you can see it
but we still want to publish it as
you have  seen I am not sending
absolutely no traffic to this
version 3 at the moment we have it there but
we want to connect to it well with the
app engine each of the  s versions is
address speaks for itself so if I
click here we will be able to see perfectly
what we have in this version of the
application
this cloud I think it still does not have a
name
our leaving message is forgiven
at least we have not known what name
they have given it  the people from the
world version organization and at the
moment we are calling it so what
is special about this version well
this version is the one that
our development people take control of instead of
being made in the standard app mode it
is made in  flex mode and
remember flex mode had some
runtimes that came but in that mode
but if we don't like that runtime or if we
need libraries that are special
we can take those libraries package
them create a recipe that in the end
is what the doctor is  file and that docker file
but to do is execute the creation of
that container within the app engine and
there we will have an environment that will have
the  s libraries that
our development people need and they will be able to
develop in their favorite language and
start working with it because
from this version 3 our
development people can take control and
start working with the version
the menu is at the  left is
super interesting it has a lot of
things that are very good we don't have
time to go into all of them but
simply a future evolution so
you can see it is this part of the dashboard
which is where we are taking the
metrics day by day and we are
doing it like this  because we're still very,
very in beta but this makes perfect
sense in the world to make it a
standalone service so that it's
absolutely decoupled from the rest of
the app and when we get that out we'll
need to decouple all the
components you're on this in particular
is using the data store  from google
cloud and above is using the merkaz
that is available within the app engine I
remember with what c  ual we absolutely do not need
any of this embedded
within our application and
we can perfectly decouple it and
turn this into a service and that
service will be the one that
our business people will use and
we will not give visibility of this part to the
rest of the application  or to the rest of the
people who connect to see the topic of
the clouds
so here now I would like to
point out the advantages that we see
from each of the teams I have already
seen that our development people
are happy because we are not
forcing them to work on  python, which is
what the application is
originally made of, with which the
flexibility in terms of the environment is
brutal, the architecture people are
also very happy because they will not
have to make a monolithic architecture,
they will rely on a lot
of services  of decoupling to be
able to create microservice environments and
that the application is capable of scaling
each of those co  components
independently do not create
bottlenecks and have the least
friction surface between each of the services
the business agent is happy about
many things firstly because of the time to
market the time to market of an
application deployed in the app engine is
brutal  second because the cost of the
platform is going to be directly
proportional to the success that the platform
has
and third because they are going to have all the
metrics they need because we
are absolutely enthusiastic about
this platform we would love for
test 6 and thank you very much
[Applause]
good  we wanted to end this session
thank you
we want to end this session concluding
with the first conclusions of everything
we have touched very very very compressed
that we have learned to focus on it in
the code this is a
fundamental advantage because because our
developers
I do not know about infrastructure my friend
enrique  yes but I don't know about
infrastructure so what I  What I
like is the code and I can be there, yes,
I give all my potential, so the
code is attached to
the business part, as Mario said, and then if we
can focus on the code, it is learning, it
will be very easy for us to
focus there  that an infrastructure is deployed to us
that we do not
have to know about but that any code is going to be very
efficient,
you see that we have done it
by seeing how to build any
kind of code with scale, everything that can be
packaged in a container is going to be
able to run  in enap in kings with
which the fact of having the application a
language that is not supported among those
that appear on our website does not have to
be
a barrier to take our
code to the app engine
and of course, as we have said, do not
see that wall either  If you have a library that
you cannot install at runtime, you
can do it and it is as simple as
downloading the dow care file that we have
seen before, adding the libraries that
you want  package it and upload it
pending that moment our
application would be executing
all the things that we have seen and this
is the compendium of urls that can be useful to you
the first three are the
demos that we have seen and if you want to
carve this with this hashtag well  look at
powell next 17 on the other hand all the
code that we have seen is in the
examples and tutorials and documentation in
cloud dot google.com app engine and in
the other 2 urls you can find all
the code of the examples that we have
been seeing today and it is  as easy as
making a clone hit this url will display
appendini you have your application
running with all this simply
thank you for attending this
talk and looking forward to hearing your
graphic challenges
[Applause]
[Music]